have a carrot help sorry about that
that's twice you just fell over hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to slime Ranger now there's
a number of things that I wanted to do
before I got back to the series and one
of those things was learn exactly how to
progress properly in the game so that I
have something to show you guys and now
that I do I first need to do some
farming and building up on my own base
before I have a good place to go from so
what you're gonna see is a time-lapse of
me failing miserably to expand my place
base base this is gonna take a while
alright so first thing I'm doing is I'm
running around and I'm gathering up the
stuff that's already on the ground and
then I'm firing pink slimes into space
as they fill up my gun unnecessarily
goodbye sayonara and then I'm going to
keep going and keep farming until I get
enough stuff that I need good thing I
did that backpack upgrade so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna have over here is
gonna be my gardening center so I got
two carrot farms that's stealing me good
and I got a fruit tree over here and
then I got another Corral over here that
I didn't necessarily need and I need to
expand it real good spring grass hmm
they'll produce eggs twice as fast fire
miser oh my god there's so much
technology that I need yeah me are you
harvest ready yet that doesn't matter
how many go terrorists don't destroy
everything that I come across give give
give give boy it'd be really sad if
trees actually complained about the
babies that I'm stealing from them oh
well let's see I can buy high walls
better better but not perfect
considering that they can still fly I
did not think that through oh these are
cool these poops are nice I'm gonna hang
these poops on my mantle later alright I
guess it's 90 buy time so I can go to
sleepy sleep
good night everybody well star mail
anything see Bob thanks Bob
uh Bob oh that was you Bob okay you look
like a slime in disguise I'm not a
hundred percent sure about this one okay
but I have far too many carrots that
ain't gonna do me any good I gotta go
out and get some steers let me see
hi whatever I'll just carry with me
there's no harm in having them cuz I
mean I was gonna harvest in here anyway
alright if I find some things that he
carrots out in the wild that I want to
get plots from and they're particularly
valuable it would do me some good what
what Plourde do you give oh oh whoa ow
ow that's fancy but hey that's good to
know because now I can harvest both
because I believe the spiky spiky ones
are worth quite a lot is ow that hurts a
lot in my face yeah okay I'm digging it
oh hello what the hell is this what's
that oh I need a key for this ah I
understand whoa what there's a
teleporter oh I didn't know that I wish
I would have known that I would have
collected more stuff I didn't
I got phosphor floored son of God rock
Lords both of which are gonna be great
cried dr. Bradley okay so I'm back with
slime rancher and I've actually done a
lot of good every one of my Corral's has
high walls you might have seen in the
closet I was doing I was playing for
quite a while just kind of talking to
myself I've got to carrot gardens over
here with an overflow of carrots over
there I've got to fruit trees over here
which I've already harvested but this
one has a few extra that I'm gonna
harvest right here because I'm going to
put in in the honey thingy an auto
feeder which should be good and should
make it a lot easier so auto feeder
proof yeah there it is
I'm gonna fill this up with fruit
there we go and now that's gonna spit
out them whenever those things in there
are hungry I'm guessing and I imagine
they look pretty happy actually probably
because they've actually been fed and
cared for because I'm a good papa and
I've got two other places here and a
chicken coop that I need to upgrade a
little bit probably with some grass ah
there we go
because I'm going to feed you to the cat
one singular cat ah yes please
hen hen coming in coming in hot look out
that was quick
great whoa okay I must be much happier
now nope still looks like the face of
sadness but I'll get to you in a second
these guys all look pretty happy over
here but now that I have these I know
what I'm gonna do next is I'm gonna
continue to upgrade my pens and I'm
gonna expand my collection to be bit
better than it was before
and to be frank I don't know why I
actually decided to recap this because
you guys probably all saw that but what
I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna go out and
farm a little bit more until I actually
have a collection of slimes
in my farm but before I do that I'm
gonna go to bed time for sleepy bye oh
look at that they got Auto fed that's so
cool that's so cool
there's also a UH automatic port
collector that I can do for this one
because that would actually make my life
a lot easier I should have gotten more
slimes but I did not know that it was
going to teleport me back even though I
should oh tabby prices went up I need to
get more cats than I didn't know they
were that valuable and I need to find an
elusive golden slin because it's gotta
be one somewhere around here and then
floor collector blam done and done where
does it collective noise oh that's so
nice all this so cool well that's so
awesome I don't think I'm supposed to be
putting anything into it am I do I need
to was that something I needed to do or
we're clearly pausing the MS storage
tank no I think it's okay I just need to
suck it out of it when they make it so
if I actually take some more the auto
feeder is currently empty yes but
thank you I'm gonna make another fruit
one because I got a lot of fruit base
doodads and it's kind of a bad dad
situation where I'm not doing what I'm
supposed to be doing running out of
farming plots I need less carrots and
more garish Dern everything else except
for carrots goddamn it I will go way too
many carrots i blurt blurt blurt blurt
oh that guy looks hungry don't worry
you'll be fed you'll be Fred oh they're
all clamoring for the feeder well they
know oh they're so smart and so hungry
can I get my can you feed them good
video can you do the feet II do thing
can you feed the feet II do they're
hungry they're hunger oh man
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to I'm gonna take some chickens
first I'll take some chickens take some
of these tickets not all the chickens
mind you I need to get another rooster
for this because I only have one
Brewster Heaney he he feels a little
outmatched in all the work that he needs
to be doing but what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go out I'm gonna pick up every
bird that I find along the way I'm gonna
try to start feeding the giant cat so
that he can eventually give me what I
need
thank you lots of whatever the currency
is okay good enough there's got to be
more and I gotta get home no mine my
Birds huh get out of here up Birds dead
bird con man those pink slimes are
ravenous it will eat anything and
everything hey boy open wide point point
point point point point point point
point point point point
bang bang bike no you're sitting on a
teleporter going back
God you ravenous [ __ ] yeah give me give
give to me don't eat up all the goddamn
things and eat them you ate up all the
goddamn things my philosophy is that
only purebred slimes deserve to be in my
farm
oh not hello roost Oh give me you I said
give me you thank you you will have a
harem you will
very happy baby okay I'll take you do
laughs why are these chickens just stuck
in boxes it seems like not a very happy
life to live oh well whatever give me
you thank you don't worry you're gonna
be studs on my farm you're gonna be very
happy good luck
look BLUP BLUP they just go sliding so
violently into their existence BLUP BLUP
BLUP BLUP BLUP BLUP BLUP and you eat
veggies that's very handy because I've
got an exorbitant amount of veggies
literally too many veggies way too many
level of level of levity Petey Petey
Petey no no no no no no nom nom nom nom
nom no no no no have you had enough
probably oh god I forgot they hurt oh
why did I get rocks limes they heard
uh-huh this is not fortunate for my
decision-making why isn't this there it
goes that's more like it daddy likes
come on vacuum up vacuum get him suck
suck baby suck no ok any more fruit
trees like a different type of fruit
fine we're going okay so now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna set up a little
bit of an auto feeder oh that would be
simple what am I getting absolutely dick
thanks that's not exactly what I want to
do slimes are more valuable to me I'm
gonna set up an auto feeder over here
point so that I can take my enormous
stock piles of carrots and actually put
them somewhere that they need to pay
thank you
it seems like like way more carrots than
fruit get produced which I don't know if
that says anything but I don't
and last Plourd input okay so we've made
a lot of progress we've done a lot of
good stuff we got an auto feeder set up
on the rock slimes
we've got an auto feeder and an auto
sucker set up on the honey slimes I've
kind of neglected all my slimes in the
cave over there but they shouldn't have
been so far away that it was easier for
me to neglect them and I've got a couple
studs in here with all the hands so that
they're gonna produce more chickens to
feed my one lonely cat who's all alone
and very sad and I feel bad about so I'm
gonna get that in the next episode thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what other things you want to
see me do and slime rancher otherwise
I'm just gonna try to keep building my
Empire bigger and bigger until I reach
narcissism extreme mode so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
Jang mi
yes stupidly dumb come angry Buffalo Wow
why don't I make you wait he's got one
elf Oh nummy nummy nummy